bei uns im studio alex im burg du
begleitet die ganze corona pandemie
schon und vor allem die sprache die
kommunikation der politik jetzt sagt uns
einmal wie gefällt dir dieser satz vom
berliner bürgermeister
ich finde es absolut empörend aber nicht
nur dieser satz des bürgermeisters
sondern man muss es im zusammenhang
stellen was kanzleramtsminister brown
gesagt hat er uns plötzlich empfohlen
hat fahrrad zu fahren dann unsere
kanzlerin gesagt wir sollen leib ist
natürlich die uhren in unseren wohnungen
machen wenn es zu kalt wird weil wir so
viel lüften wegen wegen der pandemie
das klingt erst mal lustig und witzig
und man kann darüber man kann darüber
später machen ich finde es empörend
weil es letztlich ja und dominiert ist
unser staatsverständnis
nach meinem staatsverständnisses die
politiker unsere angestellten sind
unsere dienstleister wirklich die müssen
für uns arbeiten und die benehmen sich
im moment aber wie die die uns bemuttern
können und uns in jung soo private
sphäre hinein quatschen können das ist
nicht ihre aufgabe der stadt sollen
möglichst weit weg sein das ist das
grundprinzip des freiheitlichen staates
deshalb subsidiarität fuß und man könnte
sagen dass doch warum so hochfahren
darüber reden weil solche sätze apple
langsam aber langsam auch unsere
mentalität verändern werden wir werden
irgendwann oder in ein paar jahren ist
einfach hinnehmen dass politiker in
unser leben in mein kochtopf in meinem
wohnzimmer hinein hineinregieren und das
ist nicht die aufgabe der politik wie
gesagt ich sage nochmal die politik dass
uns unsere angestellte die kanzlerin der
begriff kanzler ist von einem
schriftgelehrten sozusagen der am hofe
arbeitet um die korrespondenz für uns zu
erledigen und der kämmerer ist der
finanzminister dafür zuständig ist dass
das geld beisammen bleibt das sind nicht
leute die uns regieren sondern die für
uns und das land regieren ja viel
ärgernis also auf deiner seite wir
wollen noch einmal bei hang gent
nachgreifen und zwar wie viel ärgernis
jetzt in dieser ganzen phase war es der
satz von michael müller ist ja jetzt
eigentlich die spitze des eisberges wie
verärgert ist der einzelhandel generell
darüber wie jetzt mit ihm umgegangen
wird vor allem in den letzten wochen der
korona pandemie muss schon deutlich
sagen dass wir natürlich eine gewisse
berechenbarkeit brauchen man muss
massnahmen vorher besprechen und
ankündigen und unsere einzelhändler sind
beispielsweise heute in sachsen schon
ziemlich verärgert weil dort eben ab dem
dezember schon eine völlige laden
schließung für alle nicht lebensmittel
reden angekündigt und beschlossen wurde
und das schafft natürlich jetzt in der
zeit gerade vor weihnachten erheblichen
unmut weil dort natürlich umsätze
wegbrechen existenz nicht verloren gehen
und zum thema wirtschaftshilfen
vielleicht an der aussage weil er immer
war milliarden-summen gesprochen werden
die überbrückungshilfen
wirtschaftshilfen die bis jetzt
ausgereicht wurden sind im einzelhandel
zugute gar nicht angekommen weil die
voraussetzungen dafür gar nicht da war
das heißt die hürden um überhaupt einen
antrag stellen zu können sind sehr hoch
die sind jetzt etwas gelockert worden
für diese überbrückungshilfe die ab
januar gilt aber dennoch sind die hürden
sehr sehr groß und viele händler sagen
natürlich wenn wir jetzt schließen
müssen wie in sachsen
dann muss man uns gleich behandeln wie
auch die gastronomie die einem
umsatzausfall entschädigung bekommen und
natürlich viele händler stehen mit dem
rücken zur wand
eine frage nachher gerne momentan gilt
ja die mehrwertsteuersenkung sollte
diese jetzt verlängert werden daher die
situation tatsächlich nicht besser
geworden ist seit der entscheidung
wir haben momentan nicht das problem
einer mangelnden kaufkraft die sparquote
ist verdoppelte legten über 20 prozent
das heißt das geld ist in den haushalten
schon vorhanden aber das umfeld passt
natürlich die kannst du und sagt
deutlich wir sollen alle zu hause
bleiben die geschäfte dürften bisher
aber öffnen und viele bleiben dann aber
auch zu hause und geben das geld nicht
aus das liegt dann auch der sparkasse
und fließt nicht zurück in den
wirtschaftskreislauf die
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung als solche hat
einen hohen aufwand im handel gekostet
denken sie an den lebensmittelhandel
wenn dann 20 30.000 artikeln um
gezeichnet werden müssen und jetzt
nochmal retour wenn die erhöhung jetzt
wiederkommen wird der effekt für den
konsum war sehr gering im einzelhandel
reden wir vielleicht über drei
milliarden euro an an konsum effekt bei
einer branche die über 500 milliarden
euro umsatz macht ist das natürlich
verschwindend wenig und natürlich mit
meinem pullover kauft das bild von dem
wieder zu bedienen für für 30 euro wir
sind 25 prozent die man weniger zu
zahlen hat wenn die mehrwertsteuer
reduzieren wir natürlich nicht so
ausschlaggebend dass man gleich drei
pullover kaufen
wir haben deutlich gesagt diese wirkung
ist momentan nicht da gewesen wenn man
sich ernst haben will und
dann müsste sie möglicherweise dann erst
im nächsten jahr da sein also die
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung würde 2021
wahrscheinlich eine wesentlich größere
wirkung haben für den konsum als in
diesem jahr
vielen dank stefan genth für ihre
einschätzung rund um das einkaufs chaos
jetzt hier in deutschland dankeschön und
alexis gerade schon so ein bisschen
erwähnt der ton nicht nur bei michael
müller für dich ziemlich falsch
angeschlagen sondern unter anderem auch
bei angela merkel und deswegen wollen
wir uns einmal noch mal den o-ton
genauer anschauen
und deshalb haben wir jetzt ein
besonderen winter und man muss sich
vielleicht wirklich ein bisschen was
wärmeres noch zum anziehen mitbringen
vielleicht macht man auch mal eine
kleine kniebeuge oder so oder klatscht
in die hände damit man ein bisschen warm
wird die hände klatschen kniebeuge
machen ist dirk eilers war ich fast dass
ehrlich gesagt nicht und ich muss
wirklich noch einmal sagen die
regierungen sind nicht unsere
erziehungsberechtigten bei allem respekt
für unsere kanzlerin sie ist eben nicht
meine mutti und diese darf mich nicht
wie ein kleines kind behandeln wisst ihr
was er will was sich wessen aufgabe das
ist solche guten ratschläge zu geben
unsere aufgabe die journalisten wir
machen ratgeberseiten und wir sagen ja
körperlicher züchtigung und das ist die
diät und so weiter das ist unsere
aufgabe zum teil journalisten wir wirken
sozusagen an der meinungsbildung dadurch
teil
das ist unsere aufgabe aber sicher nicht
von der regierung sagen wir wenn das
gesundheitsministerium in das
gesundheitsministerium jetzt ein blatt
herausgeben würde mit sieben punkten wie
kommen sie fit durch die korona krise
will ich es absolut vernünftig finden
aber ich fühle mich verhöhnt wenn eine
kanzlerin die das duo zu sorgen hat dass
dieses land stabil ist und dass die
prioritäten richtig gesetzt werden wenn
die sich dorthin sekt und mir plötzlich
sagt wie lange ich mir die zähne putzen
soll was für socken ich anziehen soll
und ob ich in die hände klatschen soll
ich bin das absolut im hirn ein noch
andere merkwürdige ratschlag der kam von
ihrem kanzleramtschef hecke brauchen da
wollen wir auch einmal kurz reinhören
wir können auch im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr nicht alles durch
regulierung regeln sondern jeder muss da
auch selber ein bisschen aufwand
verwenden wir zur arbeit muss das
verstehe ich da muss man wirklich darauf
achten dass man alternative
verkehrsmittel nutzt wo es nur geht
individueller art ja vielleicht auch
fahrradfahren oder oder oder
auch dann natürlich die frage wie bist
du heute ins büro gekommen fahrrad
gefahren hoffe ich nein ich habe ein
auto genommen also so ein auto die
stehen darum in berlin
und dann kann man damit per app öffnet
so relativ modernen oder auch im auto
also relativ bin ich natürlich fahrrad
gefahren und so wie es behalten fahrer
zu fahren aber es sieht ja herr braun
ganz klar der weiß dass überhaupt nicht
glaube ich weiß nicht wann herr braun
letzte mal auf einem fahrrad gesessen
ist aber ist die inhaltlich stimmt es ja
was der kanzleramtsminister war
inhaltlich stimmt ist auch was die
bekannte was die kanzlerin sagt und auch
pullover muss man nicht wahrscheinlich
haben sie sogar sogar genug pullover im
schrank und braucht keinen puffer
zwischen jetzt und in neue jahr
das hört der einzelhandel ungern aber
noch einmal es ist nicht die aufgabe von
politikern uns da uns da rein zu reden
ich finde das unmöglich weil es wenn wir
uns wie kinder behandeln lassen dann
wird das zu einem mentalitätswechsel bei
uns führen wenn wir das jetzt durchgehen
lassen darüber einfach nur lächeln und
sagen ja wir müssen die unsere politik
auf die finger hauen und ihn als jahren
erinnern ihr seid unsere angestellten
und ihr müsst euch so wenig wie möglich
in unserem in unsere angelegenheiten
einmischen dann sei der eine gute
regierung wird das ist das prinzip der
subsidiarität also das was aber was in
der familie geregelt werden kann seine
familie geregelt was in der stadt
geregelt der stadt und es die kannst du
denn jetzt von oben sagt wie ich in die
hände klatschen soll das dürfen wir
wirklich nicht durchgehen lassen man
kann das als witz abtun ist es nicht es
ist dürfen das nicht durchgehen lassen
weil wir sonst es hinnehmen dass
politiker auch künftige generationen ist
einfach normal finden in unsere küchen
schlafzimmer und wohnzimmer
hineinzuregieren